que pensez-vous de l'estimation faite
par la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur les dégâts d'un dans les facs
à la suite du mouvement
quant au parcours sup se chiffre à 5
millions d'euros
déjà entendu purge points dont 5
millions de ventes c'est ce qu'elle a
dit ce matin bonbons les derniers
chiffres si elle parle de viol de
tolbiac pour y être allé avant la grève
s'était pas fameux les universités sont
créés blessés dans un sale état
non je écouter tout ça participe à la
communication ministre qui va payer
oui non mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que premièrement je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit les gens qui étaient mobilisés
qui est tagué sur les murs il y avait
des tas kit qui existait déjà avant elle
dit aussi fonds l'arrivée une minorité
d'étudiants finalement et que c'était
surtout des militants radicaliser dans
les facs énormément je ne partage pas ça
je pense qu'il ya eu un mouvement qui
étaient là qui progressivement aussi
peut-être a dû s'arrêter mais qui était
juste qui on le voit bien au générique
par cour suprême inégalités profondes je
suis élue de seine-saint-denis c'est la
vérité qu'à l'heure actuelle beaucoup
départ en tanzanie et des jeunes n'ont
pas eu de réponse alors que dans les
jeunes des milieux plus favorisés des
lycées parisiens il ya déjà une réponse
c'est profondément inégalitaire quand
vous êtes un lycéen de lycées
professionnels
je crois que l'auto pour l'instant de
non réponse il est de 68% alors qu'il
est beaucoup plus bas quand il s'agit de
deux lycées de milieux plus favorisés
cette réforme ne règle rien et puis
concernant l'enseignement supérieur il
ya des besoins réels parce que la
réalité c'est que alors que notre pays
aurait tout à gagner à former notre
jeunesse les conditions d'étude
aujourd'hui son parti quand dégradé il
n'y a pas assez de moyens pour
accueillir toute cette jeunesse alors
que nous en avons besoin
alors qu' une astuce gouvernementales là
dedans pour dire c'est un vieux truc
franchement le nouveau monde sait rien
il ressemble vraiment à l'ancien moi je
suis né en politique si je puis dire
contre nous vont de vacquières
novembre/décembre 86 étaient les mêmes
trucs à une bande de gauchistes à
l'époque c'est charles pasqua le disait
avec son accent marseillais à des baux
schiste de tout poil et de toutes
nationalités étaient minoritaires bon il
ya des personnes qui y est il avait
d'ailleurs terminé ici si je peux dire
bon ça m'impressionne pas
la ministre d'enseignement supérieur
comme ce gouvernement utilise les du
vocabulaire plus éculés de la droite
réactionnaire les égoïstes des petits
bourgeois les cheminots pour devoir est
de faire des grèves politiques pour
nuire au gouvernement
bon oui mais ce gouvernement lui il n'a
pas l'impression de faire de la sale
besogne franchement elle est contente de
ce qu'elle fait ils sont fiers
aujourd'hui que notre enseignement
supérieur est dans un sale état
grève ou pas grève elle est allée dans
une université mais je demande aux
parents elle a été présidente met
d'accord bien précisément les conditions
de précarité des enseignants des
conditions d'études et ça parce qu'avec
des étudiants mobilisés on va montrer
que ça va être ça le problème
d'enseignement supérieur c'est pas
sérieux